Cyberattacken Blackouts wie sicher ist
Deutschland vor russischen Hackern was
wenn unsere kritische Infrastruktur
angegriffen wird die Lichter in
Deutschland ausgehen Bild chefreporterin
Antonia Yamin besucht wattenfall den
größten Stromanbieter Deutschlands und
bekommt Zugang zu dem Raum von dem aus
alle Wärmekraftwerke Berlins gesteuert
werden das ist hier der sogenannte
Control Room wo wir das gesamte System
steuern und hier an den Wänden auch
sehen können die einzelnen
erzeugerstandorte unsere 2022 km Leitung
und natürlich auch die verbrauchsorte
wird das Netz von Hackern angegriffen
gehen die Heizung aus in Berliner
Haushalten wird es dann bitter kalt 1,3
Millionen Wohneinheiten wären betroffen
aber auch Bahnhöfe und Krankenhäuser
also auch die
IT-Sicherheit oder die Security im
Allgemeinen ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema
bei uns da haben wir Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die sich jetzt nicht erst seit
kurzem wegen anderen Krise mit diesem
Thema befassen sondern schon ganz lange
dabei sind unsere ganzen Anlagen
physisch zu sichern aber das Thema haben
sie angesprochen IT-Sicherheit hat seit
einigen Jahren einiges an Bedeutung für
uns gewonnen und das hat es weiterhin
und auch im Lichte dieser Krise
natürlich also wenn die Russin uns jetzt
angreifen ihr seid vorbereitet wir sind
vorbereitet soweit man vorbereitet sein
kann gut dass der krisenraum in der
Fernwärme zentrale nahezu komplett
analog gesteuert wird hier in diesem
Raum in dem wir gerade alle gemeinsam
sitzen das ist der sogenannte
krisenstabsraum noch mal wir sind nicht
in einer Krise deswegen haben wir auch
die Gelegenheit diesen Raum hier für
diesen Kreis heute zu verwenden aber es
scheint als würde das Thema hier nicht
allzu ernst genommen insofern sehen wir
im Moment hier keine Gefahr eines
Blackouts und insofern ist das auch
nichts worauf wir uns vorbereiten selbst
jetzt wenn man mal auf diesen Winter
guckt erwarten wir eher nicht lange
anhaltende flächendeckende Ausfälle
sondern
aber vielleicht so in den Spitzen Zeiten
wenn es mal sehr sehr kalt ist und dann
zu einer nicht verfügbar kommt dass man
so punktuell und gezielt Temperaturen
reduzieren muss oder im allerschlimmsten
Fall sogar auch abschalten muss nachdem
ich mir das heute alles angeschaut habe
kann ich sagen Deutschland ist
angreifbar es fühlt sich sogar an als
wären Unternehmen ein bisschen naiv wenn
es um dieses Thema geht beim nächsten
Angriff geht es hier nicht um
Sprengstoff sondern um Software und da
muss ich Deutschland noch massiv
verbessern
[Musik]